we now continue our discussion of the
model in which we obtain several
measurements of an unknown random
variable theta in the presence of
additive noise under the same
assumptions as before theta and WI are
all independent random variables and
they are also normal we have seen that
in this case the posterior distribution
of theta is a normal distribution and
takes this particular form we found the
mean of the posterior distribution which
is also the maximum posteriori
probability estimate and it is given by
this expression now that we have an
estimate in our hands we can ask how
good is this estimate and for this we
need an appropriate performance measure
for estimation problems a reasonable
performance measure is to look at the
mean value of the squared error but
given that we have already obtained
observations what we're interested in is
the conditional mean squared error this
is the error that's remaining after we
have seen the observations now let us
notice something here if I tell you the
value of the observations then my
estimator is completely determined the
estimator is a random variable that
processes the data and comes up with an
estimate so although it is a random
variable once I tell you the value of
the observations the value of this
random variable has been completely
determined and so we can replace it with
its actual numerical value which is fete
a heart and it is given by this
expression now remember also that theta
hat the estimate that we are using is
the mean of the posterior distribution
in this conditional universe where we
have conditioned on this information
theta hat is the mean of this random
variable so we're dealing with the
square distance from the mean and then
we take the expected value but that's
nothing but the variance of theta in
conditional universe so what we're
looking for is the variance of the
posterior distribution of theta given
the observations that we have obtained
can we eyeball the variance by just
looking at this formula for the
posterior distribution more or less we
can recall this earlier fact that if I
give you a density of this form you
recognize that it is normal and you also
recognize that the variance is
determined by the coefficient that comes
next to the term of the form x squared
now this is a PDF involving a variable X
here we're talking about the PDF of
theta so what we're looking for is the
constant that sits next to the theta
squared term there's going to be
multiple theta squared terms so we need
to collect all of them and so we find
that the overall coefficient sitting
next to theta squared terms is as
follows from this we obtain a
contribution of 1 over 2 Sigma 0 squared
and similarly from here we're going to
obtain a coefficient next to theta
squared of 1 over 2 Sigma 1 squared we
continue the same way and finally from
the last term we obtain a contribution
of this kind now we take this factor of
2 move it to the other side so we know
what 2 times alpha is and then we need
to take the inverse of that so as to
obtain 1 over 2 alpha and what we
obtained is that 1 over 2 alpha when
alpha is given by this expression is
equal to this expression here and so we
have found the conditional variance the
variance of the posterior distribution
of theta given the data that we have
available in our hands now this is the
mean squared error given that you have
seen some particular piece of
information what about the overall mean
squared error this is the quantity that
you care about before you go and make
the actual measurements this tells you
how well you expect to estimate your
random variable
theta well we can use here the total
expectation theorem and write the
expected value as a weighted average of
the conditional expectations under
different scenarios namely under
different measurements of X and average
those conditional expectations over the
possible values of X now this quantity
here is actually a constant it is this
constant here so we can pull it outside
the expectation what we're left is is
the integral of a PDF over all possible
values which has to be equal to 1 so
what we're left with is just the value
of this constant which is this
particular number and so we conclude
that the overall unconditional mean
squared error is also the same this
makes perfect intuitive sense our mean
squared error is going to take this
value no matter what I observe so on the
average it will also take that
particular value now this expression
that we have derived is also quite
intuitive in its content let us try to
understand some special cases suppose
that some of the variances of the noise
terms is very small if one term is small
this means that the corresponding term
here is going to be big so the sum of
those terms is going to be big as long
as one term is big then the sum is also
big and then one over that is going to
be small so in that case the mean
squared error is small what this is
saying is that if just one of their
measurements has low noise then the
uncertainty that remains for my random
variable that I'm trying to
mate that uncertainty will be small I'm
going to have a small error on the other
hand if all of the noise variances are
large then this means that all of these
terms here are going to be small I'm
adding small terms 1 over something
small is something big and so the mean
squared error is going to be large that
is if all my measurements are very noisy
then I do not expect to estimate my
random variable particularly well let us
now look at one more special case
suppose that all the variances are the
same the noise variances as well as the
variance of the prior distribution in
that case this expression here is going
to become one over we have the sum of n
plus 1 terms and each one of those terms
is 1 over Sigma squared which is the
same as Sigma squared over n plus 1 this
expression makes quite a lot of sense it
tells us that if we obtain more and more
observations that is as n increases we
improve our performance the variance of
the posterior distribution or the mean
squared error goes down in this
particular way now perhaps the most
interesting aspect of the facts that we
have established is this equation here
that tells us that no matter what this
value of little X is the conditional
variance the variance of the posterior
distribution of theta is going to be the
same in some sense it tells us that no
particular value of x is more
informative or more desirable than any
other value in order to really
appreciate what that statement is really
saying it's better to look at a very
concrete example so let us revisit the
very first example that we studied in
which case we only have one observation
and
we're theta and W are standard normal
random variables we did go through that
example and we found that the estimator
the maximum posteriori probability
estimator was one half of the
observation and now we're in a position
to also calculate the conditional mean
squared error given any particular
observation we apply this formula in
fact we're dealing with this special
case with Sigma equal to one so we use
this expression here and we see that it
is one half so we started with the prior
variance for theta which was one and
after we obtained the observation or
uncertainty gets reduced and the
variance goes down to one half and this
is true no matter what little X is
pictorially here is what's happening we
start with theta being a standard normal
so it has a distribution of this form
centered at zero this is a plot of the
density of theta the prior density
suppose that we obtained a measurement
and that measurement happens to be equal
to zero if the measurement is equal to 0
then our estimate will also be equal to
0 the posterior distribution of theta is
going to be a normal distribution whose
mean is the estimate and whose variance
is this quantity that we have calculated
which is 1/2 and therefore it is
narrower than the original PDF that we
started from so initially we had a fair
amount of uncertainty about theta
after we obtained a measurement of 0
this kind of reinforces our belief that
theta is somewhere near 0 and so we
obtained an error distribution this is
our updated belief about theta but what
if I happen to obtain a measurement that
somewhere out here in this case my
estimate
is going to be one half of what I
observed here and the posterior PDF of
theta is going to be a normal PDF that's
centered around this point and has the
same variance one half so in some sense
this particular measurement would be
thought of as a quite abnormal one we're
really surprised to obtain an
observation which is so far away from
zero because our prior distribution told
us that theta is somewhere here so we
have been surprised but after the
surprise and after we form our estimate
of theta our state of knowledge about
theta is that theta is a random variable
and it has a distribution that's normal
centered around this point and whose
width is the same no matter what
particular observation I happened to get
so even though this particular
observation value is unusual after it is
obtained the remaining uncertainty about
theta is the same as if we had obtained
any other particular value of x so this
is a very remarkable property that's
special to this type of estimation
problems involving normal random
variables and linear relations it has a
very nice side effect it means that we
can report we can say anything there is
to be said about the performance of this
maximum posteriori probability estimator
by just giving a single number we can
characterize performance only in terms
of this number as opposed to having to
tell what this conditional mean squared
error is for the different values of x